from epic performances to big wins
who know a thousand views on me ET is
highlighting the best moments from the
2019 Latin Grammys we're gonna do a
tribute to all the 20 years of Latin
Grammys so I'm really happy to be part
of that I need that kicked off the show
with a salsa tribute to the lace Elia
Cruz
[Music]
Prince Royce was part of the same
performance but instead he honored the
late John Sebastian
[Music]
I was able to perform with him a few
years back before he passed away so
we're really just celebrating his legacy
his music Rosalia was the most nominated
female artist of the night she took home
three Awards including Best urban song
Best Contemporary Pop Vocal album and
the big one album of the year
Cresselia
instead you're stayin shook it says
everything we're gonna spit out who
don't go to yours bonus was honored at
the 2019 Latin Recording Academy person
of the year's impossible to be here and
they'll be emotional about it you know
I'm happy working for my life since I
was a kid so now this is like a the
result of many many years
[Music]
the Colombian singer hit the stage with
a mash-up of his biggest hit
[Music]
the Award for Best urban album went to
rapper bad bunny by bunny
the mega tornado use his speech to show
his support for urban music quando
rapido area palpable - Raveena Robinson
tengo mucho dinero Musa garlic jalapeno
bad bunny also perform his new song with
resident a and Ricky Martin cantaloupe
et caught up with resident their
backstage just moments after winning his
25th Latin Grammy not only did you win
but that performance with Ricky Martin
bad bunny was something else for us was
incredible like we had the opportunity
to be part of a huge massive protest in
Puerto Rico and he was so beautiful to
see like people you know it was bad what
was happening but it was beautiful like
the energy of the people trying to make
it better
the audience went wild for Alicia Keys
and Miguel the pair graced the stage
with a bilingual performance of show me
love
[Music]
you were also joined by Pedro Kapoor and
paruko for a special rendition of karma
Gamla took home the Latin Grammy for
song of the year
[Applause]
what a year what a night
congratulations man thank you brother
happy happy to be here I mean it's my
birthday too Awards happy to be
surrounded by you know my peers that I
have so much respect and admire what a
night and we said that Fernandez
received a standing ovation after
delivering a touchy performance with his
son Alejandro Fernandez and grandson
Alex Fernandez
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]